so we've now officially been on the air
for five years didn't think that would
happen glad it did some of our more
sentimental producers put together some
highlights here they are
welcome to the first edition of the
eponymously named tucker carlson tonight
show i got a haircut for the show we're
glad you're here we're gonna get back to
basics here we're gonna hold the
powerful accountable pierce pomposity
translate double speak mock smugness and
barbecue nonsense every night hope you
watch can you look right into the camera
and say i know for a fact the government
of vladimir putin was behind the hacks
of john podesta absolutely the
government of vladimir putin was behind
the hacks of our institution and the
dominance of john podesta not only in
the united states
but also in europe okay you're not you
know what you're dodging
tucker inauguration day for the new
president and the new first lady it all
began with a swearing-in ceremony i
donald john trump do solemnly swear
tucker you're not accusing this me of
being a hoax are you
i'm saying that your name is fake and
this company is fake and that the claims
you've made on your website are false
we're in the middle of a thunderstorm
we're at a jail in el salvador this is
reputed to be
the best bartolina in the country
a model facility which is probably the
reason they took us here do you know how
many of these men are suspected of being
ms-13 uh quite a number why do you think
so many political and cultural leaders
in the united states disagree with you
and are making the case that borders are
themselves immoral it's incredible i
mean the democrats are for open borders
which means crime our crack control room
team just minutes ago spotted the creepy
porn lawyer in his natural habitat well
the rest of us were distracted by the
creepy porn lawyer we have a standing
invitation for the creepy porn lawyer to
appear on this program whenever he
desires when's the last time you saw
porn oh you busted me actually made a
humiliation porn that's why i watched
you on cnn standing on the north korean
board of the president with the south
korean president president moon about to
meet with the north korean leader
hey come on come on
bye wait till they move come on
wait till we move mr president how do
you feel
feel great it's a great honor to be here
a mysterious virus spreading in china
has gotten hundreds of people sick at
the top of the hour the death count has
doubled to nearly 25 so far that we know
of the chinese government has
quarantined the city of wuhan where the
virus originated but in one case
in this country is already confirmed
fauci is the high priest of the covid
cult a paper mask is his sacred garment
cable television is his pulpit the
people of washington bow before father
fauci
what happened last night in minneapolis
was not a political protest it was a
riot happy inauguration day it's a big
moment for the country there's a new
regime in power starting today and they
seem to be planning to accelerate things
dramatically they're getting the fbi and
the pentagon involved in this hunt for
people who may criticize them good
evening and welcome to a special edition
of tucker carlson tonight we're coming
to you from budapest here's victor orban
his accent's pretty thick but his
english is precise he's worth hearing
you have to defend your people against
any danger and you think you have a
right to do that of course
it's cut from the it's coming from the
god the nature so all arguments with us
we'll be back that's our promise 8 pm
every weeknight the show that is the
sworn enemy of lying pomposity smugness
and groupthink we hope you have the best
night with the ones you love and we will
see you soon
hard to believe it's been five years
what a great time it's been
many have tried to end it earlier than
that
but you've stuck in there we're grateful
for real
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else